[Music]
the Solera above the solar energy makes
a very important contribution for a
start in terms of capacity after just 18
months we're already producing more than
120 megawatts of solar energy that's
very significant it's around 1/5 of the
capacity in Senegal we are continuing to
expand it further by an additional 100
megawatts scaling salons and I've got a
summing over the solar look I won't
we have other sources of renewable
energy such as wind energy we're aiming
to produce an additional 150 megawatts
from wind in Senegal on top of solar
power our renewable energy sources our
wind Sun and hydropower Livan we
combined all three of these natural
resources with conventional energy
sources what's also different given
quality really systemic classic
[Music]
woloson Megalodon Senegal is doing a lot
to tackle climate change
we welcome German efforts in Africa to
boost investment in this area including
the g20 initiative which is a pact for
the whole of Africa not the mob within
this partnership
I believe Germany is a very important
player in this field
Philemon Lamont Rama along with other
African leaders I will be visiting
Germany to examine this new pact with
Africa mom I'm just a little mantra
Gatlin I look good to do this on energy
production and climate change will most
certainly be at the top of the agenda
with this new cooperation motley
muttering war premiere on this at New
York or Paris
[Music]